et puis pour clôturer ce chapitre au
sport le circuit bugatti a reçu cet
après midi une visite un peu
particulière michel colucci plus connu
sous le pseudonyme de coluche étaient en
effet venus assouvir sa passion pour les
grosses cylindrées folle ambiance au
passage de coluche sur le circuit
bugatti
il faut dire que notre pitre nationale
était venu essayer une moto il a plu
toute la journée ont rendez-vous raté
puis non non merci non déjà en voiture
c'est bon pour la bretagne c'est un beau
temps mais pour la moto c'est un temps
de chiottes
[Musique]
la moto que coluche devait essayer c'est
ici avec le side-car divan migros qui
dansent nice est 7e à elle faisait moto
2000 qui a créé la surprise en arrivant
troisième aux dernières 24 heures
coluche y était la moto ça fait un
moment qu'ils aiment ça fait combien de
temps on peut dire mon âge c'est pour la
télé 25 ans et la compétition non
pollution
c'est pour ceux qui savent vraiment
faire des manteaux moi c'est pour
c'est pour faire peur mais des fois ça
peut m'arriver plantes à leurs âmes le
rêve de sa vie devant peur oui bien sûr
très intéressant
rien
[Musique]